I have for you today may be the single
most disgusting picture or image from
the Trump presidency Donald Trump has
done things that have had far more
far-reaching implications and that
affect way more individual people but
this picture and the story behind it
represent the absolute basest low of the
lows of the Trump presidency and really
of Donald Trump as a person Donald Trump
went to El Paso Texas to I guess offer
some kind of comfort to the victims of
the mass shooting that took place there
last weekend at least ostensibly that's
why he was going although understandably
a ton of the victims wanted nothing to
do with Trump specifically because this
is the last person that's able to offer
comfort or empathy to anybody some of
the victims reportedly just weren't
accepting visitors or weren't in a
physical condition to accept visitors
and that's understandable as well so the
trumpet man administration learned about
a baby that had been orphaned by the
shooting a two month old baby both of
whose parents had been killed in the
shooting Donald Trump heard about this
and had the baby brought back to the
hospital where Trump was after having
been discharged the University Medical
Center El Paso and was in a truly vile
and disgusting photograph looking
absolutely thrilled with the same smile
and double thumbs-up that Trump employs
after you know cheating on a golf
tournament and winning or whatever while
Melania Trump holds the baby this is the
epitome of a disgusting photo op this is
not how normal people function and how
they behave in society a normal person
wouldn't have had the baby brought back
to the hospital a normal person wouldn't
look ecstatic to be photographed with a
baby whose entire life has just been
turned upside down by the brutal murder
of both of the baby's parents and what's
even worse is that during this visit to
El Paso Donald Trump bragged about the
crowd sighs the last time he was in El
Paso this video is of Trump speaking to
emergency workers first responders
people working hour
hours to try to clean up the tragedy
that was this horrific mass shooting
which politically Donald Trump is
unwilling to do anything about here is
Donald Trump saying you know I had just
such a great crowd last time I was here
and making fun of better O'Rourke was
here three months ago we made a speech
and we had a statement what was the name
of the arena that place was packed right
right the judges of respect what was the
name we had twice the number outside and
then you had this crazy babe a towhead
like four hundred people he's meeting
with first responders and he makes fun
of another presidential candidate who's
actually from El Paso and who actually
shows empathy and understanding for the
tragedy that has been suffered and he
talks about the size of his crowd the
last time that he was there what's most
notable here is it Trump's lack of
empathy is it again like is this
cognitive decline that always comes up
but I don't want to give Trump an easy
out he may genuinely genuinely just be a
terrible person who doesn't care about
anybody else but cognitive decline comes
up again he doesn't know to do anything
other than thumbs up and grin when a
photograph is being taken how sick are
terrible of a person do you need to be
to think using an orphaned boy as a
photo op prop and grinning your way like
a doofus through it is even remotely
appropriate and then to brag to the
people there about the size of the crowd
the last time you were in El Paso and it
sort of makes sense that for Donald
Trump he thinks of all of these visits
as just another visit in other words the
last time Trump was in El Paso he had a
big crowd he's back for another visit so
he talks about the crowd last time it's
no different that last time it was a
build the wall Magga rally and this time
it's because of a mass shooting at which
a whole bunch of people died and were
injured for Trump it's just another
visit where he believes himself to be
the center of attention
believes that he should be the center of
attention and believes that what
everybody cares about is getting
pictures with him and hearing about how
great his last visit was and how stupid
Beto or
or whatever else consider for a second
who benefits from this photo it's not
the baby it's not the hospital it's not
the other victims this is a photo that
only benefits Trump particularly when
you consider that the baby had already
been discharged and was asked to come
back by Donald Trump in his
administration and by the way I mean I
don't even I don't even know that it
makes sense to go down this road because
it's just you know you know where it'll
go the baby being Hispanic who knows how
that is going to be spun by Trump and
the administration and you know Trump
does show empathy it's not fair to say
that Trump doesn't care about the kids
in cages the Latin American kids in
cages look at Trump in the picture with
the baby well the baby was a prop in the
picture and Trump was grinning like a
buffoon and holding two thumbs up an
unconscious unconscionably vile moment
of the Trump presidency and there have
been many but really summed up
incredibly concisely by this picture
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that i use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
Escom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five
five bucks a month that's be Li NK is
t.com /pa k ma n